community.
They reveal something about creativity,
our ingenuity --
they even hint at our identity.
And when bridges fail,
or are destroyed in conflict,
communities struggle,
development stagnates, people suffer.
Even today,
there are over one billion people living in poor, rural communities
around the world
that do not have safe, year-round access
to the things that you and I take for granted:
education, medical care, access to markets ...
which is why wonderful organizations like Bridges to Prosperity
build bridges in this kind of place -- this is in Rwanda.
And they make such a difference,
not only to those lives immediately around the bridge,
but the impact of these bridges is huge,
and it spreads over the whole community,
far, far away.
Of course bridges have been around for an awfully long time.
The oldest ones are stone because it's a very durable material.
I don't know about you --
I love to look at the development of technology
to learn about what people did with the materials
and tools available to them at the time.
So the Pont Du Gard in the center is a wonderful example --
Roman aqueduct in the South of France --
fantastic piece of technology built using massive stones put together,
dry -- there's no mortar in those joints.
They're just dry stone joints --
fantastic
and almost as good as new today.
Or sometimes up in the mountains,
people would build these suspension bridges,
often across some dizzy canyon,
using a vine.
In this case, this is in Peru.
This is using grass which grows locally
and is woven into ropes to build these bridges.
And do you know they rebuild this every year?
Because of course grass is not a durable material.
So this bridge is unchanged since Inca times.
And bridges can be symbols of their location.
Of course, Golden Gate and Sydney are well familiar.
In Mostar the bridge was synonymous with the name of the place,
and to such an extent that in the war in 1993
when the bridge was destroyed,
the town all but lost its identity until the bridge was reconstructed.
And bridges are enormous features in our landscape --
not just enormous, sometimes there's small ones --
and they are really significant features,
and I believe we have a duty to make our bridges beautiful.
Thankfully, many people do.
Think of the stunning Millau Viaduct in the South of France.
French engineer Michel Virlogeux and British architect Lord Foster
collaborated together to produce something
which is a really spectacular synergy of architecture and engineering.
Or Robert Maillart's Salginatobel Bridge in the mountains in Switzerland --
absolutely sublime.
Or more recently,
Laurent Ney's beautiful and rather delicate bridge
for Tintagel Castle in the UK.
These are spectacular and beautiful designs
and we need to see more of this.
Bridges can be considered in three convenient categories,
depending on the nature of the structural system
that they adopt as their principal support.
So, bending, of course, is the way a beam will behave --
so, beams and bending.
Or compression is the principal way of operating for an arch.
Or for the really long spans you need to go lightweight,
as we'll see in a minute,
and you'll use tension, cables --
suspension bridges.
And the opportunity for variety is enormous.
Engineers have a fantastic scope for innovation and ingenuity
and developing different forms around these types.
But technological change happens relatively slowly in my world,
believe it or not,
compared to the changes that happen in mobile phone technology
and computers and digital technologies and so on.
In our world of construction,
the changes seem positively glacial.
And the reason for this can be summarized in one word:
risk.
Structural engineers like me manage risk.
We are responsible for structural safety.
That's what we do.
And when we design bridges like these,
I have to balance the probability that loads will be excessive on one side
or the strength will be too low on the other side.
Both of which, incidentally, are full of uncertainty usually,
and so it's a probabilistic problem,
and we have to make sure
that there's an adequate margin for safety between the two, of course.
There's no such thing, I have to tell you,
as absolute safety.
Contrary to popular belief,
zero risk doesn't exist.
Engineers have to do their calculations and get their sums right
to make sure that those margins are there,
and society expects them to do so,
which is why it's all the more alarming when things like this happen.
I'm not going to go into the reasons for these tragedies,
but they are part of the reason
why technological change happens quite slowly.
Nobody wants this to happen.
Clients don't want this to happen on their projects, obviously.
And yet of course they want innovation.
Innovation is vital.
As an engineer, it's part of my DNA.
It's in my blood.
I couldn't be a very good engineer if I wasn't wanting to innovate,
but we have to do so from a position of knowledge and strength
and understanding.
It's no good taking a leap in the dark,
and civilization has learned from mistakes since the beginning of time --
no one more so than engineers.
Some of you may have seen this film before --
this is the very famous Tacoma Narrows Bridge collapse
in Tacoma, Washington state,
1940.
The bridge became known as "Galloping Gertie"
because she -- she?
Is a bridge female? I don't know.
She was wobbling like this for quite a long time,
and notice this twisting motion.
The bridge was far too flexible.
It was designed by a chap called Leon Moisseiff,
no stranger to suspension bridge design,
but in this case he pushed the limits just that little bit too far
and paid the price.
Thankfully, nobody was killed.
But this bridge collapse stopped suspension bridge development
dead in its tracks.
For 10 years nobody thought about doing another suspension bridge.
There were none.
And when they did emerge in the 1950s,
they were an understandable overreaction,
this sort of oversafe response to what had happened.
But when it did occur in the mid-60s,
there was indeed a step change --
an innovation, a technological step change.
This is the Severn Bridge in the UK.
Notice the aerodynamically streamlined cross section
in the center there.
It's also a box which makes it very torsionally stiff --
that twisting motion which we saw at Tacoma would not happen here.
And it's also really lightweight,
and as we'll see in a moment,
lightweight is really important for long spans,
and everybody seems to want us to build longer spans.
The longest at the moment is in Japan.
It's just under 2,000 meters -- one span.
Just under two kilometers.